meet an emotional adele posting a video  to social media saying that all of her  dates for her las vegas residency will  be rescheduled weekends where the dell  was scheduled to begin tomorrow at the  coliseum at caesars the singer had lined  up two shows each and every weekend  through mid-april in that video the  singer blames delivery delays she also  says about half her crew and team are  down with kovid and they just haven't  been able to pull the show together  there were no specifics given on the new  dates just that more information would  be coming soon the show must go on but  not in this case caesar's palace  released in a statement a short time ago  that reads in part we fully support  adele and are confident the show she  unveils at the coliseum at caesar's  palace will be extraordinary